marilou bruxelles
bonjour à tous suite de l'examen ce
matin du projet de loi sur la sécurité
intérieure
depuis deux jours les sénateurs
examinent ce texte dans un climat très
frondeur et un la commission des lois a
rejeté trois des amendements phare du
gouvernement
et hier après midi en séance publique
l'opposition a longuement combattu le
texte par le biais de trois motions qui
portait sur la baisse des effectifs sur
le désengagement de l'état ou encore sur
le bilan sécuritaire ce matin nous vous
proposons de revenir sur la séance
d'hier soir qui portait sur la
cybercriminalité ou encore la question
de la pédopornographie sur internet
également au programme ont dû fiche à
tout l'enjeu du débat est de savoir
comment améliorer le fichage
électronique avec les empreintes
génétiques
sans pour autant porter atteinte à la
liberté des personnes tout de suite
retour à la séance d'hier soir
très belle séance à vos nous reprenons
la discussion du projet de loi adopté
par l'assemblée nationale d'orientation
et de programmation pour la performance
de la sécurité intérieure dans la
discussion des articles sommes parvenus
à l'amendement numéro 113 au sein de
l'article iv et nous avons donc six
amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune donc tout d'abord
l'amendement 113
il est présenté par madame à sa merci
mais ce président cet article 4 vise à
obliger donc les fournisseurs d'accès en
ligne d'empêcher sans délai l'accès à
des services de communication au public
en ligne dont les adresses sont ont été
notifiés par l'autorité administrative
et ce pour le domaine particulier de la
diffusion des images ou représentations
des mineurs de mineurs à caractère
pédopornographique donc à l'origine je
voudrais rappeler que la notification
par laurie l'autorité administrative
devait être précédée de l'accord de
l'autorité judiciaire
mais
un amendement a permis que cet accord ne
soit plus requis ceci au motif que celui
ci serait susceptible de recours selon
la procédure de droit commun alors pour
notre part nous considérons qu il
revient à l'autorité judiciaire qui est
quand même la gardienne des libertés de
se prononcer sur des mesures
susceptibles de porter atteinte à la
liberté de communication et ce quelle
que soit la gravité de l'infraction
supposée pour illustrer mon propos je
vous rappelle que le conseil
constitutionnel a estimé
s'agissant de la loi hadopi qu'une
connexion ne pouvait être coupés sans
décision du juge est qu'une autorité
administrative ne pouvait pas prendre
une telle décision il est donc
vraisemblable que la mesure que vous
souhaitez institué qui se passe donc de
l'intervention du juge judiciaire soit
potentiellement soumise à la même
sanction
donc nous estimons que toute mesure de
blocage doit être prescrite par le juge
judiciaire
par ailleurs le pas le texte instaure la
création d'une liste noire de sites qui
se verront privés d'un accès au réseau
internet liste noire qui est définie par
l'autorité administrative
mais je dois dire que nous n'avons pas
beaucoup d'éléments pour savoir comment
les autorités compétentes bord ou
actionner la procédure en renvoyant ces
questions à un décret réglementaire et
nous estimons que cette procédure doit
être défini par la loi
par ailleurs il est aussi inquiétant que
rien ne soit aujourd'hui en mesure de
garantir la publicité de cette liste et
nous considérons également que ces
mesures ne doivent pas s'adresser
uniquement aux fournisseurs d'accès
internet comme le permet en l'état le
texte mais également aux hébergeurs afin
de renforcer
l'efficacité de telles mesures donc je
dois dire que nous restons un peu
circonspect sur les préconisations qui
nous sont faites dans cet article et je
crois qu'avec cet amendement nous
voulons en tout cas c'est ce que
souhaitent les villes de mon groupe
une amélioration des dispositions
introduites à l'article 6 de la loi de
confiance en l'économie numérique
merci chers collègues amendement 199
il est présenté par monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues c'est l'une des surprises
peut-être de ce débat l'assemblée
nationale a été plus vigilante que le
scénar sur le pouvoir judiciaire
nous connaissons le destin de cet
article est de cet amendement est ce
qu'il faut oui ou non un contrôle
judiciaire pour le fitr à un filtrage de
ces sites
l'assemblée nationale dès la commission
des lois avait dit oui et donc avait
prévu cette autorisation est sous
contrôle judiciaire
l'assemblée nationale a voté cette ce
et nous en commission des lois à notre
surprise
eh bien nous avons considéré que
finalement pour une fois l'autorité
administrative pouvait suffire
je pense que l'assemblée nationale a eu
plus de sagesse je regrette de le dire
que nous dans cette affaire pourquoi
parce que nous allons nous heurter
immédiatement évidemment à la décision
du conseil constitutionnel du 10 juin
2009 est donc également aussi à la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et à
son article 11
nous allons nous heurter ça alors
pourquoi dans un souci d'efficacité
c'est bien je m'imagine bien que c'est
le motif qui est qui est invoquée
comment voulez vous que l'on bloque des
adresses avec un juge judiciaire dans
des délais qui soient convenables oui
mais d'abord il ne s'agit pas de bloquer
le site
premier point il s'agit uniquement de
bloquer les adresses moi il me semble
que pour bloquer les adresses donc
repérer les adresses mail des personnes
qui accèdent
opéré des personnes qui accèdent au site
on peut peut-être prendre le temps de
saisir le juge judiciaire bien entendu
va pas le faire par une procédure au
fond mais on connaît tous ce qui est des
procédures accélérées et qu'en
particulier des procédures en la forme
des référés qui pourrait tout à fait
convenir et nous permettre ainsi cette
garantie du juge judiciaire à laquelle
nous sommes tant attachés
merci chers collègues amendement numéro
il est présenté par madame boumédiene
thiery oui monsieur le président et cher
collègue le ministre
cet amendement concerne l'autorisation
des autorités judiciaires pour la
suspension de connexion un peu dans le
même sens que mes collègues précédent
l'article 4 poursuit en effet un but
tout à fait légitime qui est celui de
lutter de manière efficace contre la
pédopornographie et en permettant et en
mettant en oeuvre une procédure de
notification impliquant les fournisseurs
d'accès et obligeant ces derniers à
suspendre les sites internet
pédopornographiques en s'appuyant sur
les opérateurs
si nous adhérons à l'objectif de cet
article en revanche nous avons quelques
réticences en ce qui concerne la
procédure qui est suivie il est en effet
prévu que l'autorité administrative
puisse intervenir sans contrôle de
l'autorité judiciaire pour limiter ce
droit d'accès à internet et le droit de
diffusion des opérateurs une telle
possibilité en effet ne semble contraire
à la jurisprudence du conseil
constitutionnel tel que développé dans
sa décision du 10 juin 2009 selon
laquelle une décision judiciaire est
requise pour toute restriction de
l'accès à internet
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous vous
proposons de restaurer l'intervention de
l'autorité judiciaire qui pourra dès
lors apprécier s'il existe comme le
prévoit le texte
une représentation manifestement
pornographique de mineurs dans le cas
contraire cette prose aide procédure
serait alors contraire à la constitution
puisque l'autorité judiciaire est garant
du respect des libertés dont l'accès à
internet fait partie et je ne pense pas
que nous pouvons nous permettre de ne
retrouver une fois de plus en
contradiction avec notre
institution merci merci chers collègues
le 89 tons bleu 309 rectifié amendements
identiques il est présenté par madame
escoffier merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre
chers collègues je vais reprendre les
arguments qui viennent d'être
développées notre notre amendement écrit
dans la même forme a pour objet de
subordonner la procédure de blocage des
sites à caractère pédopornographique à
l'autorisation de l'autorité judiciaire
et dont et de ce fait de se conformer à
la jurisprudence constitutionnelle
je rappelle que dans une décision de
2009 2009 580 dc du 10 juin 2009
relative à la loi création et internet
le conseil constitutionnel a justement
affirmé la compétence exclusive de
l'autorité judiciaire
on suspend la zone est considérée alors
comme une liberté fondamentale
par conséquent il ne peut pas appartenir
à l'administration seul par
l'intermédiaire des hébergeurs et des
opérations de communication électronique
de porter atteinte à ce principe et
c'est pour ça que nous souhaitons que le
set
cette proposition est cette notification
pour faire intervenir l'autorité
judiciaire puisse être prise en compte
merci chers collègues nous arrivons à
l'amendement numéro 4 il est présenté
par monsieur détraigne un merci monsieur
le président cet amendement est
légèrement différent de ceux qui
viennent d'être présentées à l'instant t
il ne remet pas en cause de dispositifs
prévus aujourd'hui par l'alinéa 3 de
l'article iv en ce qui concerne les
sites manifestement ayant un caractère
manifestement pédopornographiques mais
il vise à combler à un manque qui est
celui des sites ayant un caractère
pornographique mais qu'on ne peut pas on
peut pas qualifier de manifestement
pédopornographique pour cela donc il est
prévu les travers de cet amendement que
l'autorité administrative il saisir
l'autorité judiciaire qui jugera s'il ya
lieu ou pas d'engager les procédures
concernant l'interdiction d'accès à ce
site
merci cher collègue monsieur rapporteur
quel est l'avis de la commission
merci monsieur le président monsieur
ministre sur l'amendement 113 la
commission avait supprimé l'exigence
d'une autorisation de l'autorité
judiciaire pour permettre aux services
de police que blocage de sites à
caractère pornographique
cette autorisation était introduite par
l'assemblée nationale contre l'avis de
son rapporteur jones souligné
l'argument avancé par l'initiateur cette
modification fondée sur les décisions du
conseil constitionnel concernant la loi
du 12 juin 2009 favorisant la diffusion
et la protection de la création sur
internet n'avait pas convaincu notre
commission en effet l'ascension du
conseil constitionnel avait alors porté
sur le pouvoir donné à l'autorité
administrative de restreindre ou de
limiter l'accès à internet considéré
comme une atteinte à la liberté
individuelle
or la disposition proposée présente une
porte est beaucoup plus restreinte
puisqu'elle tend non interdire l'accès à
internet mais à empêcher l'accès d'un
site déterminé en raison de son
caractère illicite
notre commission des lois avec néanmoins
jugé utile pour un amendement que
j'avais présenté de mieux préciser le
champ d'intervention de l'autorité
administrative limiter aux sites
présentant un caractère manifestement
pédopornographique
par ailleurs le choix des dresse
électroniques dont l'accès doit être
bloquée constituera naturellement une
décision administrative susceptible de
recours dans les conditions de droit
commun
donc avis défavorable il en est de même
pour l'amendement 199 même pour le
moment 41 est identique pour
l'amendement 309 rectifié en revanche
pour l'amendement numéro 4 cet
amendement prévoit en cohérence avec la
garantie introduite par la commission
des lois que lorsque le caractère
pornographique n'est pas manifeste
l'autorité administrative peut saisir
l'autorité judiciaire qui statue alors
sur l'interdiction de l'accès aux sites
concernés
cette précision est apparu utile à
commission des lois mais un avis
favorable
merci monsieur important monsieur
ministre l'avis du gouvernement
si monsieur le président même avis que
le rapporteur ici en effet en deux blocs
en rien l'accès de quelqu'un internet
vous l'avez dit mais on bloque l'accès à
des images dans le contenu est lui-même
illicites et donc il n'ya pas de liberté
d'accéder à des contenus illégaux donc
la question en réalité ne se pose pas
donc même avis que le rapporteur et sur
les autres amendements monsieur ministre
en bleu des âmes ont compris sur le 4ème
prix sur leucate et l'argumentaire du
rapporteur
il est convaincant alors nous votons sur
le 113 pas de demandes d'explications de
vote que ceux qui souhaitent adopter
veuille bien levé la main défavorable
sur le 4-1 j'ai peut-être commis un
lapsus l'a prouvé à part dont plus de
m'excuser je le mets dans le rythme
d'accord c'est le début de la session
donc qui qui adopte l'amendement numéro
113 si vous voulez bien voter lever la
main merci que ceux qui sont contre veut
bien levé la main il n'est pas adoptée
même vote donc sur le 199 sur le 41 sur
le 309 rectifier nous en arrivons à
l'amendement numéro 4 donc je rappelle
l'avis favorable de la commission
avis défavorable du gouvernement pas de
demandes d'explications de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent l'adopter veuille bien
levé la main
merci que ceux qui sont contre eux
veulent bien levé la main il est adopté
nous en arrivons à l'amendement numéro
deux sens il est présenté par madame
tess merci monsieur le président
monsieur ministre chers collègues
puisque j'ai pas réussi malheureusement
à vous convaincre que le blocage des
sites pédo pédopornographiques étaient
une fausse bonne idée
au moins entendez ce nouveau plaidoyer
pour qu'on ne le fasse que pendant un
délai de un an délai qui va nous
permettre effectivement de vérifier
l'efficience de vérifier si des sommes
et les moyens techniques mis en face ont
des résultats en regard de ce que l'on
peut attendre ou si c'est ça mais ces
moyens techniques ne pourrait pas être
mieux utilisé par ailleurs pendant ce
délai d'un an
voyons voir ce que l'on peut faire en
matière de d'éducation en matière de
formation en matière de logiciels de
contrôle parental obligatoire etc etc
donc cet amendement demande à ce que le
dispositif de blocage des sites
pédopornographiques ne soient instituées
que pour une durée d'un an au bout de
laquelle un rapport serait remis afin de
juger de l'efficacité réelle de ces
dessertes de cet argent public et de
l'utilisation de cet argent public pour
la lutte efficace et effrénée contre la
pédopornographie merci chers collègues
merci d'avoir totalement respecté le
temps on peut pas être mauvaise à tous
les coups et c'est le président alors si
on apporte alors quel est l'avis de la
commission
je présente se munissent cet amendement
propose que le dispositif de blocage des
sites pédopornographiques soient mises
en oeuvre de manière expérimentale et
qu'un rapport soit soumis au parlement à
l'issue d'une période d'un an le premier
point le caractère expérimental
impliquerait que le législateur
intervienne de nouveau dans un an ce qui
paraît lourd et peu efficace regarde la
lutte contre cette forme de criminalité
quant au rapport il me semble qu'il
existe d'autres moyens plus efficaces
pour permettre au parlement de
s'informer et de contrôler l'action du
gouvernement sur une question qui en
effet requiert la plus grande attention
la commission envi donc mis un avis
défavorable
merci monsieur l'inventeur monsieur le
ministre la vie du gouvernement
oui même avis que la commission je pense
que la démarche d'évaluation car il faut
une évaluation pourrait intervenir dans
un délai au minimum de 24 mois merci
monsieur ministre pas de demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter cet amendement va
bien levé la main merci que ceux qui
sont contre veuille bien levé la main il
n'est pas adopté un amendement 201
il est présenté par madame ps dans la
mesure où c'était un amendement de
coordination avec le 200 qui est le 190
je crois qu'il n'a pas été adopté je
pense qu'ils tombent naturellement plus
mon amendement 202 29 alors le 202 vise
à déterminer les modalités d'exercice du
droit d'accès au traitement des données
résultant des notifications
administrative par la commission
nationale de l'informatique et des
libertés
en effet les articles que nous venons de
voter ou de ne pas voter mais qu'en tout
cas viennent d'être adoptée prévoit que
le ministère de l'intérieur va fabriquer
et transmettent une liste noire des
adresses électroniques qui seront à
bloquer autrement dit création d'un
nouveau fichier sans forcément l'après
fichiers et même si nul ici je pense ne
peut contester l'intérêt effectivement
de ce fichier
donc pour autant en l'état actuel des
connaissances il s'appelle pas fichés et
il serait intéressant à la fois pour les
risques de surblocage notamment comme
pour le contrôle du droit informatique
et libertés que l'ensemble de ces
données soient contrôlés par la cnil
c'est ce à quoi vise cet amendement
merci cher collègue monsieur rapporteur
l'avis de la commission se présente
soumise cet amendement vise à préciser
que le décret détermine les modalités
d'exercice droit d'accès de la cnil au
traitement des données résultant des
notifications administrative l'objet
poursuivi est de garantir aux
responsables des sites une voie de
recours
il convient de rappeler qu'en tout état
de cause les responsables des sites
peuvent utiliser les voies de recours
administratifs de droit commun cette
précision n'apparaît donc pas utile la
commission des lois a émis un avis
défavorable
merci le sur important monsieur le
ministre oh oui mais supposions et mai
la vie est souvent plus que leur accès
en direct devant la cnig ne s'applique
qu'aux traitements de données à
caractère personnel et la liste des
sites faisant l'objet d'un blocage ne
correspond pas aux pratiques
merci monsieur le ministre pas de
demandes d'explications de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent adopter cet amendement
venir lever la main merci que ceux qui
sont contre veuille bien levé la main
l'amendement n'est pas adopté un
amendement numéro 114
il est présenté par madame associe oui
merci monsieur le président il s'agit
ici de demander que le dispositif
répressif qui est introduit au présent
article soit mise en oeuvre sur à titre
expérimental sur une période de 12 mois
et que le législateur puisse procéder à
son évaluation
l'évaluation je voudrais dire détaillé
avant d'entamer une éventuelle
pérennisation bonjour ne revient pas ici
ce fléau que constitue la pédo
pornographie sur internet je crois
qu'ici nous sommes il ya au moins un
consensus pour dire qu'il faut le
combattre
collectivement et qu'il faut
effectivement se doter d'un arsenal
juridique performant avec bien
évidemment des moyens humains
nécessaires
mais cela dit nous nous pensons que les
mesures qui sont préconisées ici
présente quelques risques de dérives en
table de liberté de communication
et que cela risque de s'avérer inutile
donc le dispositif de filtrage qui est
conçu donc par cet article 4 risque
selon nous d'être compris contre
productif puisque ce n'est pas
l'existence même de tels sites qui
combat mais simplement leur accès or on
sait très bien qu'en termes d'accès
l'évolution des technologies permet
systématiquement que lorsque de nouveaux
filtrage sont créés mais est ce bien est
immédiatement de nouveau contournement
sont également créés et donc à terme ce
il nous sans que ce dispositif
entraînera fatalement le développement
de modes de diffusion plus difficilement
détectables par les enquêteurs selon les
opérateurs
je les cite les solutions de blocage ne
permettent d'empêcher que les accès
involontaires à des contenus
pédopornographiques disponible sur le
web à travers le protège le protocole h
de tp n'est pas d'empêcher les réseaux
pédophiles de prospérer il est à
souligner que tous les contenus diffusés
diffusés sur les réseaux peer to peer ne
sont pas inscrits dans le périmètre de
blocage or d'après une enquête
ce sont ces réseaux qui sont depuis 20
ans une des principales plateformes
d'échangés d'imagés pédo pornographiques
fin de citation ceci sans compter le
coût de telles mesures de filtrage dont
nous ne savons dont nous n'avons
aujourd'hui aucune estimation
alors ma collègue ma collègue martine
billard à l'assemblée nationale avait
considéré je partage son point de vue
que pour empêcher les mineurs d'avoir
accès à ces images l'une des solutions
réside rey également dans l'instauration
d'un logiciel d'un logiciel de contrôle
parental qui permet de filtrer sur
chaque ordinateur l'accès aux imans aux
images donc en tout état de cause nous
demandons par cet amendement pour le
moins une évaluation de ce dispositif
avant de le rendre pérenne merci chers
collègues monsieur le rapporteur de
l'avis de la commission
écoutez comme l'on vient de rejeter
l'amendement deux sens que c'est le même
la commission peut maintenir clavier
d'événements défavorables monsieur le
ministre même avis défavorable pour les
oiseaux même avis pour le gouvernement
pas de demandes d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter veuille
bien levé la main merci que ceux qui
sont contre veuille bien levé la main
l'amendement n'est pas adopté nous
votons sur l'article 4 pas de demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter veuille bien levé la
main article 4 merci que ceux qui sont
contre veulent bien levé la main il est
adopté
article 4 bis pas d'explications de vote
même vote
il est adopté nous en arrivons chapitre
iii utilisation des nouvelles
technologies sur l'article 5 que j'ai
une demande de parole de madame eliane
assassi merci monsieur le président donc
c'est cet article 5 est le premier du
chapitre droit donc y est consacrée vous
l'avez dit monsieur le président à
l'utilisation des nouvelles technologies
donc on y découvre en fait l'usagé que
vous comptez faire des avancées
informatiques de ces dernières décennies
pour selon nous mieux contrôler chacun
de nos concitoyens
mais contrairement à votre habitude on
note ici que vous ne craignez que vous
ne créez pas deux nouveaux fichiers
ouf mais peut-être la liste est-elle
déjà tellement longue qu'un ajout serait
effectivement inutile en revanche vous
détourner les fichiers existants de leur
finalité d'origine si vous permettez je
trouve cela un peu plus pernicieux ainsi
aux termes des articles 5 et 8 de ce
texte le fichier national automatisé des
empreintes génétiques pourra par exemple
contenir les empreintes de victimes de
catastrophes naturelles ou celle des
ascendants descendants ou collatéraux de
personnes figurant dans un fichier de
police
il nous semble quand même que c'est là
la porte ouverte au fichage des
empreintes génétiques de toute la
population
donc ce fichier qui à l'origine est un
fichier judiciaire deviendra ainsi ou
deviendrait ainsi un fichier civile ou
la carte la carte génétique de chacun de
nous pourra être consulté par les
autorités publiques
alors le fait que vous ne prévoyez pas
de séparation entre les données
concernant les différentes catégories de
personnes fichées doit peut-être être
compris comme le révélateur de vos
objectifs alors ils elles il y a trois
ans lorsque notre actuel ministre de
l'industrie avait déclaré je le cite que
les citoyens seraient mieux protégés si
leurs données adn été recueillis dès
leur naissance en citations ben je dois
dire qu'il ne croyait pas ce cas de le
dire si bien
peut-être avez-vous oublié monsieur le
ministre en rédigeant ce projet que
cette remarque avait suscité au delà de
l'émotion dans l'hexagone avait quand
même suscité l'indignation de nos
voisins européens
entre 2003 et 2006 le nombre de profils
enregistrés au snack
nike est passé de 2008 107 à plus de 330
milles et grâce à vous et bien ce
chiffre risque de croître de façon je
dirais exponentielle et cela au mépris
des libertés publiques
mais visiblement cette violation criante
des libertés ne paraît pas vous arrêter
il n'a d'ailleurs tiré aucun vous n'avez
d'ailleurs tiré aucun enseignement de
toutes les vielles levée de boucliers
qu'avait suscité en son temps la
création du fichier edvige et les
critiques opposé à l'époque par la cnil
à cette création visiblement ne vous ont
pas servi de leçon
rappelez-vous la cnil avait émis de
grave réserves concernant en particulier
la collecte d'informations relatives aux
mineurs de plus de 13 ans votre projet
permet pourtant le fichage dans les
fichiers de police judiciaire comme dans
les fichiers d'analysé sérielle des
spécifié sans limitation d'âge on ne
peut même plus dire
que vous ignorez les objections d'une
autorité indépendante donc tels que la
cnil
je dirais même qu'on pourrait constater
qu il les méprise de façon ouvertement
donc avec la loppsi
on pourra donc procédé au fichage de
chaque citoyen et dès sa naissance
les conclusions du fameux rapport
bénisti auront sans doute inspiré
l'auteur de ce projet nos enfants sont
des ruines avant tout des délinquants en
puissance alors pourquoi ne pas les
fichiers dès leur sortie de couveuses me
direz vous
donc vous ne tenez pas compte des
critiques de la cnil vous ne comprenez
pas en compte celle de la cncdh qui
s'est elle aussi élevée contre le
dérapage de ce projet mais s'agissant
plus particulièrement de la cncdh
la démarche est est assez cohérente
pourquoi respecte auriez-vous des
réserves émises par une autorité dont il
a récemment vous avez récemment organisé
la disparition faute de pouvoir l'amusé
alors que le team hm
pour ce qui nous concerne qu'il relève
de notre devoir de rappeler ou de vous
rappeler que si le votre gouvernement
peut museler et mettre à bas nos
autorités de contrôle interne il sera
quand même un peu plus difficile de
faire la sourde oreille européenne pas
de l'homme condamnant la france pour
violation des libertés fondamentales
rappelez-vous en décembre 2008 le
royaume uni a déjà été condamné que sa
législation permettait la conservation
dans des fichiers de police les
empreintes digitales échantillons
cellulaire et profil génétique des
prévenus après la conclusion que ce soit
par un acquittement ou pas une décision
de classement sans suite des poursuites
pénales mené contre eux or là le le
projet qui nous est soumis contient des
dispositions qui sont identiques à
celles condamnée par la cour européenne
donc je pourrais conclure sur le fait
qu'aucune entrave aux droits de l'homme
m'arrête ne vous arrête lorsqu'il s'agit
de disposer d'une fiche sur chaque
citoyen
merci chers collègues je n'ai pas
d'autres demandes d'explications de vote
sur l'article 5 que ceux qui souhaitent
l'adopter veuille bien levé la main nous
votons sur l'article 5
que ceux qui sont pour adopter l'article
5 veuille bien levé la main merci que
ceux qui sont contre veuille bien levé
la main il est adopté
article additionnel après l'article 5
amendements numéro 115
il est présenté par monsieur fisher oui
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
eh bien je souhaite poursuivre la
démarche d'héliades assassi en proposant
à travers cet amendement un article
additionnel qui est ainsi rédigé et bien
entendu cela pour clarifier très
clairement notre position qui vient
d'être développée à savoir que les
dispositions de ce projet de loi donne
au fichier national des empreintes
génétiques fichiers purement judiciaire
une finalité qui n'est pas la sienne
ce fichier de police ne peut en effet
contenir des empreintes de personnes
présumées disparues ou sa parentèle la
collection de ces données impose la
création d'une base de données
distinctes pour éviter tout risque de
dérapage et d' amalgame
on a à ce titre déjà malheureusement pu
apprécier les limites des fichiers stic
et judex qui font notamment crème que
les emprunts d'inde une parentèle se
retrouve mêlée à celle des délinquants
et là nous avons des exemples que l'on
pourrait citer nous estimons que la
modification apportée au texte par
d'autres commissions des lois visant à
imposer un enregistrement distincts des
données si vide
certes c'est un mieux nous le concédons
mais n'apportent pas toujours les
garanties souhaitées
cette modification du texte qui a pour
but de prendre en compte les critiques
s'est mise tant par le président de la
cnil que par la commission nationale
consultative des droits de l'homme
ne permettra pas une parfaite étanchéité
des données et cela nous en avons
longuement discuté avec notamment la
ligue des droits de l'homme
c'est sa proposition eh bien nous
souhaitons vivement qu'un fichier
administratif spécifique soit créée pour
rassembler les données qui doivent
rester purement civil merci de ce
président richert collègue monsieur
rapporteur l'avis de la commission se
munissent cet amendement vise à créer un
fichier d'empreintes génétiques
spécifiques dédiés aux recherches
densification des personnes décédées
inconnu afin de séparer les roches à
l'identification finalité administrative
des recherches à finalité judiciaire en
réalité le dispositif retenu pour le
projet de loi satisfait le même objectif
à moindre coût puisqu'il prévoit
l'article 8 la création d'une sous base
étanche du fichier national des
empreintes génétiques qu'on appelle
traditionnellement le flag ceci limitera
la consultation des données de l'asu
base au sol recherche concernant
l'identification d'une personne décédée
inconnu j'ai juste que la commission des
lois à renforcer les garanties ainsi
présentés d'une part en garantissant le
bénéfice net en chute et à toutes les
empreintes génétiques recueillis pour
l'identification d'une personne disparue
et d'autre part en créant une procédure
d'effacement des empreintes génétiques
recueilli donc un avis défavorable
merci monsieur rapporteur monsieur le
ministre le gouvernement
oui avis défavorable pour les mêmes
raisons merci pas de demandes
d'explications de vote explications de
notre monsieur fisher viennent dire on
qu'on aurait toutes les garanties quant
aux procédures d'effacement via ça nous
voudrions bien pouvoir le vérifier car
nous savons que de nombreux fichiers et
bien aujourd'hui contiennent un certain
nombre de données qui depuis plusieurs
années aurait dû être effacées et je
crois que dans la crainte que nous
formulons et bien c'est à la fois
concrétisé l'expérience que l'on a de
l'utilisation d'un certain nombre de
fichiers et à partir de là et bien ne
pas croire
finalement pour arrêt prendre pour
argent comptant ce que l'on nous dit
parce que bien
souvent on dispose pas des moyens pour
mettre à jour les fichiers et en termes
de personnel avec la rgpp
on voit bien que la justice est bien se
trouve mutilés et certaines obligations
et bien par là ne sont pas tenues et
respecté merci chers collègues pas
d'autres demandes d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter cet
amendement veuille bien levé la main
merci que ceux qui sont contre veut bien
levé la main il n'est pas adopté nous
votons sur l'article 6 pas de demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter cet article veuille
bien levé la main merci que ceux qui
sont contre veuille bien levé la main il
est adopté un amendement sur l'article 7
un moment deux sans trois madame
boumédiene thiery
oui chers collègues l'identification
d'une personne par ses empreintes
génétiques nous permet de reposer la
question de l'immigration et du
regroupement familial
en effet monsieur le ministre vous vous
souvenez il ya quelques mois
votre collègue monsieur besson ministre
de l'immigration a décidé de ne pas
signer le décret d'application de
l'article 111 6 du code de l'entrée et
du séjour met en place le test ou te de
l'adn pour les candidats étrangers au
regroupement familial
nous sommes nombreux ici à nous être
élevées contre ce texte inique contraire
aux principes de notre république est
inadapté aux réalités sociales et
familiales contemporaine en violation
totale des règles du droit international
privé français ce test adn faisait
présumé le caractère frauduleux les
actes d'état civil étranger rendant le
test adn seul à même de prouver une
filiation disqualifiant ainsi d'autres
liens que les liens du sang à l'image de
l'adoption par exemple véritable
défiance à l'égard des pays
d'immigration
ce test adn suggéré que l'étranger
étaient par nature fraudeurs et que les
autorités étrangères sous développés
incapable d'établir des documents
authentiques et bien évidemment nous
nous sommes satisfaits de cette décision
de monsieur besson
même si nous déplorons que cette
décision de ne pas mettre en oeuvre les
tests adn soient fondées sur le
caractère impraticable de la mesure crée
et non pas en raison de son caractère
indigne et inacceptable
aujourd'hui nous souhaitons aller
beaucoup plus loin dans la logique est
supprimé ce test adn
c'est pourquoi nous vous proposons la
suppression de l'article l 111 6 du code
de l'entrée et du séjour des étrangers
et du droit d'asile
merci merci chers collègues monsieur le
rapporteur l'avis de la commission se
présente ce ministre cet amendement vise
à supprimer la procédure de vérification
d'état civil d'une personne candidate
regroupement familial sur la base d'une
expertise génétique au motif que le
ministre de l'immigration de
l'intégration identité nationale
développement solidaire n'est pas signer
les décrets d'application du texte
ceux ci ne pourront être mises en oeuvre
dans le délai imparti traiter cette
question dans le cas du présent texte
n'est pas forcément approprié
en effet cette procédure est uniquement
mentionné par renvoi par présente
article par reprise du texte actuel de
l'article 226-1 28 du code pénal aucune
modification n'est apportée
la question est soulevée par l'auteur de
l'amendement relève plutôt du prochain
projet de loi sur l'immigration annoncé
par le gouvernement il convient donc de
renvoyer cet amendement à l'examen de ce
texte pour cette raison la commission
des lois a émis un avis défavorable
l'institution à porter monsieur ministre
l'avis du gouvernement oui merci
monsieur le président même avis pour les
mêmes raisons avec la précision on a
bien compris que l'autre amendement
était motivé par la volonté de supprimer
le dispositif spécifique de vérification
des actes d'état civil pour les
candidats au regroupement familial
je veux quand même rappeler que la
procédure d'identification génétique que
vous visez spécifiquement dans votre
propos elle réalise et volontairement à
la demande de l'intéressé
elle répond elle n'est pas imposée elle
répond à un besoin à un besoin pardon
puisqu'elle vise à permettre de
confirmer des liens familiaux que les
actes officiels ne parviennent pas
forcément à démontrer de façon certaine
et ce sont des situations auxquelles on
est confronté de manière concrète très
régulièrement en quelque sorte il ya
même là une dimension de garanties
complémentaires et nous ajoute par
rapport à ce que vous pourriez évoqué
comme risques d'abus de cette procédure
dont je rappelle l'esprit et le sens
c'est bien c'est une procédure
extrêmement encadré dans ses modalités
comme son objet et il convient de
sanctionner les personnes qui
recourraient illégalement à
l'identification génétique
lorsqu'elle n'est pas autorisé par la
loi donc on ne fait pas n'importe quoi
et l'article 7 que nous proposons vise
bien à mettre en cohérence les
dispositions du code pénal avec celle du
code civil est donc on ne peut
effectivement en complément de ce que
vient de dire le rapporteur au nom de la
commission que se pose est que nous
opposer votre amendement madame merci
monsieur le ministre pas de demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter cet amendement
veuille bien levé la main merci que ceux
qui sont contre veuille bien levé la
main l'amendement n'est pas adoptée nous
votons sur l'article 7
la demande d'explications de vote que
ceux qui souhaitent adopter veut bien
levé la membre merci que ceux qui sont
contre veuille bien levé la main il est
adopté un amendement sur l'article 800
arrivants l'amendement 116
il est présenté par monsieur des rames
coordination vous avez raison
nous votons sur l'article ou 8 pas de
demandes d'explications de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent l'adopter veuille bien
levé la main merci que ceux qui sont
contre veuille bien levé la main il est
adopté l'article 9 c'est supprimer nous
en arrivons à l'article 9 bis amendement
419 il est présenté par monsieur le
rapporteur au nom de la commission des
lois
oui cet amendement précise le mode de
financement du fonds de soutien à la
prise technique et scientifique que la
commission des lois a créé par l'article
9 bis ce financement sera assise sur la
valeur des biens retrouvés et non sur
les polices d'assurances
j'ai d'ailleurs recueilli l'accord des
assureurs ce soit de financement
j'essaie qu'une négociation devrait
avoir lieu entre ceux-ci et me saljic
d'économie de finance pour fixer les
modalités du prélèvement très rapidement
pour se font plus est opérationnel bien
évidemment la commission des lois a bien
évident favorable sur mon amendement si
je suis à bordeaux
alors messieurs ministre la vidéo et le
gouvernement est favorable à cet
amendement et favre a pas demandé que le
gouvernement est favorable
c'est ce que nous disions merci pas de
demandes d'explications de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent l'adopter veuille bien
levé la main merci que ceux qui sont
contre veut bien levé la main il est
adopté
nous votons sur l'article 9 bis pas de
demandes d'explications de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent l'adopter veuille bien
levé la main que ceux qui sont contre
eux bien levé la main il est adopté
article additionnel avant l'article 10
amendements 204 il est présenté par le
président il s'agit d'un d'un amendement
dans le fruit qui est le fruit de des
apports successifs des réflexions sur la
question du contrôle des fichiers qui
ont été menées à l'assemblée nationale
et au sénat
il pose un principe général simple
permettant de sortir du débat partisan
tout en ménageant les intérêts des
services relevant tant de la sécurité
intérieure que de la défense et de la
sûreté de la nation voilà le principe
contre les fichiers de police passe par
la loi dans la mesure où la question
relève bien des garanties fondamentales
accordées aux citoyens pour l'exercice
des libertés publiques pour lesquelles
la lys l'acteur est appelé à fixer les
règles
aux termes de l'article 34 de la
constitution mais son application ne va
pas être rigides ainsi les traitements
qui répondent à une même finalité porte
sur des catégories de données identiques
et dont les mêmes destinataires doivent
être autorisées par un acte règlement
unique
le texte de l'amendement précise
également les éléments d'information et
des usages qui doivent accompagner la
création de ces fichiers
il préserve la compétence exclusive du
pouvoir réglementaire pour les
traitements intéressant la sûreté de
l'état où la défense avec un contrôle de
ces fichiers par la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement et il va
ya organisé un système un régime pendant
spécifique pour les mineurs visant à
réduire la durée de conservation des
données personnelles les concernant
notre proposition nous semble équilibré
est là sur l'action des forces de
l'ordre de la justice mais elle le fait
ta transparence et dans le respect des
libertés publiques
ainsi les personnels jeu monsieur le
rapporteur quel est l'avis de la
commission
je vais vous le donne et monsieur le
président ce ministre
le présent amendement reprend le texte
de l'article iv de la proposition de loi
de monsieur détraigne de maïs scoffier
vie privée à l'heure des mémoires
numériques
il est semble préférable de ne pas
transférer à nouveau ces dispositions
qui trouvent leur origine dans une
proposition de loi de simplification du
droit qui était présente à l'époque
monsieur bergman sa commission des lois
donc mais un avis défavorable
merci monsieur rapporteur monsieur le
ministre sur l'avis du gouvernement oui
monsieur le président autorisé la le
sénateur autorisé la création de tous
les fichiers de police par la loi n'est
pas une proposition nouvelle et je
voudrais répéter ce que nous avons déjà
eu l'occasion de le dire nous avons à
l'heure actuelle vous le savez une
répartition des compétences entre la loi
et les règlements et
elle semble à la fois intelligente
adapté opérationnel et surtout
respectueuse de la constitution de plus
la loi informatique et libertés
détermine les règles de création des
fichiers de police et par les choses
n'importe comment même quand il n'y a
pas besoin d'une loi spécifique et elle
impose de plus un certain nombre de
garanties notamment sur la finalité des
bases de données sur leurs modes de
contrôle et cette répartition et nos
respectueuses des libertés individuelles
et là qu'il rend sur chacune d'ailleurs
de ses bases de données
un avis motivé et publié est donc cette
démarche
toutes ces garanties et en rappeler est
également compatible est nécessaire d
compatible pardon avec les nécessités
opérationnelles des services mais encore
une fois dans le strict respect des
principes que je viens de rappeler
merci monsieur le ministre alors nous
votons sur le 204 y at il des
explications de vote
s'il n'y en a pas que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter veuille bien levé la
main merci que ceux qui sont contre
veuille bien levé la main il n'est pas
adopté un amendement sur l'article 10
amendements 117
il est présenté par madame la barre
chers collègues cet article comme le
suivant procède à la codification dans
le code de procédure pénale des articles
relatifs aux fichiers de police de la
loi pour la sécurité intérieure de 2003
en créant un chapitre réservé à ces
fichiers
mais il élargit le champ des données
collectées il place les fichiers de
police sous le contrôle des procureurs
de la république contrôle dont la portée
sera donc relative étant donné que ces
derniers sont sous la tutelle de
l'exécutif
pourtant le contrôle de l'accès de
l'utilisation des fichiers de police
devrait être assurée par l'autorité
judiciaire qui aux termes de l'article
66 de la constitution et la gardienne de
la liberté individuelle
or le parquet n'est pas une autorité
judiciaire du fait de sa dépendance à
l'égard de l'exécutif la référence et la
commission européenne des droits de
l'homme arrêt medvedev
du 10 juillet 2008 l'article prévoit que
les données relatives aux personnes
définitivement innocentés pourrait être
malgré tout conservé dans les fichiers
pour des raisons liées à la finalité du
fichier formule dépourvu de la moindre
signification
les personnes innocentées par la justice
non pas par définition d'antécédents
sauf évidemment dans d'autres affaires
or on voit des tontes mal pour quel
motif
les informations les concernant
figureraient dans les fichiers
d'antécédents judiciaires
si ce n'est pour d'autres à faire pire
l'article oblige au maintien des
informations dans le fichier même
lorsque les personnes bénéficient d'un
non lieu ou d'un classement sans suite
autrement dit on considère comme
antécédents justifiant le fichage une
procédure qui s'est révélée vaine
ce type d'élargissement pourra donc
faire tripler de volume les fichiers
d'antécédents judiciaires
pour toutes ces raisons nous demandons
la suppression de l'article 10 merci
cher collègue monsieur le rapporteur
avis de la commission se poser dans ce
ministre mende man 10 du projet de loi
codifie à droit constant
pour beaucoup de ces dispositions le
droit en vigueur relatifs aux fichiers
d'antécédents judiciaires
ces outils ont démontré leur efficacité
leur suppression proposée par cet
amendement entraverait sérieusement à la
lutte contre la délinquance donc on peut
mettre qu'un avis très défavorable
merci monsieur répertoire monsieur le
ministre la vidéo gouvernement oui
monsieur le président en effet même avis
l'article 10 du projet de loi modifie
les dispositions existantes sur les
fichiers d'antécédents judiciaires
les traitements d'analysé sérielle et le
fichier des personnes recherchées tout
en les adaptant aux nécessités
opérationnelles et surtout en renforçant
les garanties apportées aux personnes et
le texte par exemple institua magistrats
spécialement chargée de contrôler le
fonctionnement des fichiers
d'antécédents judiciaires et des
traitements d'analysé sérielle et celui
ci donc bénéficiera d'un accès direct
aux fichiers et détiendra des pouvoirs
d'effacement et de rectification
identiques à ceux du procureur de la
république et donc ce serait tout de
même paradoxal par cet amendement de
supprimer en supprimant l'article 10 du
projet de loi
cet égard en tissu droit actuel est donc
renoncer ainsi assez à ces garanties
nouvelles proposées par le gouvernement
avis défavorable merci monsieur le
ministre
pas de demandes d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter cet
amendement va bien levé la main merci
que ceux qui sont contre veuille bien
levé la main il n'est pas adopté trois
amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 9e rectifié 10 il
est présenté par monsieur le sert
peut-être non le 9 rectifié bis
m
on le code de procédure pénale un
chapitre consacré aux fichiers de police
judiciaire reprenant la rédaction des
dispositions actuelles les dispositions
proposées autorise l'enregistrement
dance et traitement d'informations
nominatives
or depuis la loi du 6 août 2004 cette
notion d' information nominative a été
remplacée par celle de données à
caractère personnel
loin de se réduire à un changement de
vocabulaire cette évolution a modifié le
fondement
notre droit des fichiers la notion de
données à caractère personnel n'a pas le
même sens que la notion de données
nominatives
il s'agit de toute information relative
à une personne physique identifiée
occupe et être identifiées par référence
à un numéro d'identification
elle repose sur des éléments qui sont
des éléments cumulatif éléments
cumulatif qui sont d'une part un élément
dit dédiant d'identification c'est à
dire l'identité de la personne ou tout
élément la ronde ont identifié à bhl et
d'autre part une information quelle
qu'en soit la nature relative à cette
personne il en résulte qu aucune
information des qualifiables de données
à caractère personnel en soi mais que l
inverse toute information peut être
données à caractère personnel être une
donnée à caractère personnel
l'amendement propose et met donc le
droit spécial des fichiers de police
judiciaire en cohérence avec le droit
général des fichiers tels qu'ils
résultent de la loi de 78 modifiée en
c'est la raison pour laquelle mon
collègue buffet a souhaité vous le
proposer si chers collègues amendement
120 il est présenté par monsieur fisher
bien entendu nous poursuivons nos
démarches pour bien clarifier le sens de
l'utilisation des fichiers et pour
faciliter vos tâches monsieur le
président mon explication de vote sur
l'amendement 120 vaudra pour
l'amendement 121 122 123 124 et 125 et
que je suis de bonne humeur soit
c'est la rentrée alors ces amendements
visent à garantir que les dispositifs du
fichage dont il est fait mention ne
porte pas atteinte à la vie privée de
nos concitoyens et à s'assurer qu'ils ne
deviennent pas s'ils ne sont pas déjà
des instruments de surveillance de la
population
ainsi nous souhaitons a ajouté
l'obligation d'informer les personnes
dont les données sont enregistrées dans
les fichiers de la possibilité de
s'opposer à ce que les informations
nominatives les concernant soient
conservées dans le fichier
dès lors que l'auteur des faits a été
définitivement condamné
si la possibilité est garantie dans la
rédaction actuelle du texte il demeure
impératif que l'information des
personnes concernées devienne une
obligation légale à peine de nullité de
la procédure
ils relèvent également du bon sens de
prévoir que quelle que soit la nature de
la décision ayant mis hors de cause la
personne concernée et bien que les
données personnelles la concernant soit
tout effacer des fichiers et cela
rejoint la réflexion que je faisais tout
à l'heure en présentant un amendement
par ailleurs nous le disions le contrôle
de l'accès de l'utilisation des fichiers
de police devrait être assurée par
l'autorité judiciaire qui aux termes de
l'article 66 de la constitution et la
gardienne de la liberté individuelle
or le parquet n'est pas une autorité
judiciaire du fait de sa dépendance à
l'égard de l'exécutif
conformément à la jurisprudence de la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
dès lors nous estimons également
nécessaire que les personnes concernées
disposent d'un recours qui doit être
traitée par des magistrats indépendants
afin d'obtenir une décision sur leurs
demandes d'effacement de rectification
des données nominatives
les concernant dans l'hypothèse où le
procureur rejetterait ou ne statueraient
pas sur ses demandes dans le délai qui
lui est imparti par le texte
et conformément au droit au recours donc
chaque citoyen doit disposer voit la
télé l'objet de l'explication de ses
différents membres sur le président et
c'est pour cela que nous n'aurait
interviendront pas sur les 10
amendements
merci chers collègues nous voyons vous
avez une grande expérience de la
présidence alors nous passons un
amendement 205
il est présenté par monsieur péroné et
que 10 du projet de loi accorde aux
victimes d'infractions à la loi pénale
la faculté de s'opposer à ce que les
informations nominatives les concernant
sont conservés dans le fichier dès lors
que l'auteur des faits a été définie
étant définitivement condamné il se lève
donc la question sensible de
l'information des personnes mentionnées
dans les fils you know cédant alors
qu'elles n'ont plus à y être inscrits
c'est une question tout à fait
importante à ajaccio retenu vise à ne
pas alourdir la procédure mais elle
revient à accorder un droit théorique si
les victimes inscrits dans ce traitement
de données ignorent qu'elles y figurent
les enquêteurs doivent pouvoir mener
leur enquête en toute confidentialité
mais dans le cas présent ils seraient
des victimes et les dossiers sont jugés
et a été retoqué qu'une telle obligation
d'information créerait une charge qui
deviendrait très réactive rapidement
insurmontable pour les services
gestionnaires mais dans l' annexe on
peut lire la qualité de ce lien tissé
avec la population sera d'autant plus
grande que les victimes seront prises en
charge avec toute la considération qui
leur est dû si le gouvernement prévoit
l'extension du dispositif de pré plainte
pour contribuer je cite à améliorer
l'accueil des victimes en facilitant les
marchés
g l'argument de la surcharge de travail
ce n'est pas très convaincant enfin nous
avons été convaincus par la vie de la
cncdh du 17 avril 2010 qui préconise que
les textes prévoient un traitement
séparé des personnes mises en cause des
témoins et des victimes ainsi que
l'effacement automatique ça qui importe
en particulier des données concernant
ces fichiers à l'issue des opérations
judiciaires voilà le sens le dessus le
président de notre amendement
si cher collègue monsieur le rapporteur
l'avis de la commission sur ces trois
amendements présentés unis sur
l'amendement 9 rectifie biz cet
amendement propose d'harmoniser le droit
des fichiers de police judiciaire avec
le droit général des fichiers en
remplaçant la terminologie informations
nominatives passa plus précise et plus
rigoureuse comme l'expliqué jean rené
lecerf de données à caractère personnel
la commission a émis un avis favorable à
l'amendement 120 cet amendement prévoit
que victimes sont expressément informé
des données les concernant dans les
fichiers à peine de nullité de la
procédure
cette disposition paraît excessive en
l'état du droit tu le psy ne modifie en
rien les victimes ont évidemment un
droit d'accès à ces données et peuvent
s'opposer leur conservation dès lors que
l'auteur des faits a été définitivement
condamné avis défavorable il en est de
même pour le moment 205
merci monsieur rapporteur monsieur le
ministre la vie du gouvernement oui la
ville ouverte on est similaire il est
favorable à l'article 9 rectifié bis
pour les raisons qui ont été fort bien
explicité à l'instant par monsieur
lecerf fait par monsieur le rapporteur
je n'y reviens pas concernant les deux
amendements 120 et 205 l'avis est
défavorable le rapporteur a déjà repris
quelques arguments
la venue à 13 de l'article 10
ne fait sur ce point que reprend le
droit actuel je le rappelle et dispose
que les fichiers d'antécédents
judiciaires peuvent contient des
informations sur des victimes et que
celles ci peuvent toutefois s'opposer à
ce que les informations nominatives les
concernant soient conservées dans le
fichier de l'or que l'auteur des faits a
été défini a été définitivement condamné
les fichiers d'antécédents comme tous
les fichiers de police cette fois sont
pourtant déjà soumis au droit d'accès de
rectification et il est donc tout à fait
inopportun d'imposer administration une
nouvelle charge aussi lourde qu'inutile
nous avons déjà les garanties
suffisantes comme je viens de le
rappeler on y renonce pas mais je crois
que c'est bien comme cela et donc c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous y sommes
défavorables
merci monsieur le ministre nous votons
donc sur le neuf rectifié bis pas de
demandes d'explications de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent adopter veuille bien levé
la main merci que ceux qui sont contre
veuille bien levé la main il est adopté
sur le 120 que ceux qui souhaitent
l'adopter veuille bien levé la main
merci que ceux qui sont contre vrai bien
levé la main il n'est pas adoptée sur le
205 même vote même vote
vous venez de suivre les débats portant
sur l'examen du projet de loi sur la
sécurité intérieure
prochain rendez vous de l'actualité
politique le 19 heures de michel
grossiord très bonne journée à vous sur
public sénat